- [Voiceover] In early 2020,
Leigh Whannell raked in
over $100 million at the box office
on just a $7 million budget,
and breathed new life
into Universal's previously
comatose Dark Universe.
- Go.
- [Voiceover] And he did by...
(woman gasps)
scaring the pants off of
us with Invisible Man,
which is an incredible feat,
considering the villain
is, well, invisible.
How is it that lead
Elizabeth Moss could have us
peeking through our fingers with fear
from just gazing across an empty kitchen?
How did Stephen Spielberg
and John Williams
send chills down our collective spines
with just two notes on the piano?
And why does Hitchcock's swirl
of blood in black and white
still have us checking who
else is in the bathroom
every time we step into the shower?
(water running)
(woman gasps)
So let's break down what exactly scares us
at the movies today and how
that's evolved over time.
The history of horror on screen
dates back to before the
Golden Age of Hollywood,
but our concept of a horror
movie really kicked off
with Universal's monster films.
- It's alive!
- [Voiceover] Dracula,
Frankenstein, the Mummy,
and yes, the Invisible Man,
all released in the early 1930s
and gave birth not just
to some of the oldest
film franchises on screen,
but also gave us one of the defining ways
that filmmakers would employ to terrify us
for decades to come.
In this case, monsters.
(Frankenstein screams)
Any horror movie or horror
hybrid can be broken down
into one of these essential scare tactics:
monsters, suspense, gore,
the sudden or unexpected
and the idea that seemingly
ordinary aspects of our lives
are in fact terrifying.
(demonic screaming)
And although there's
overlap and exceptions,
these sub-genres also
mirror the progression
of horror films over the decades.
Universal Studios kicked things off
with their monster movies
in what would become known
as their Dark Universe.
- I am Dracula.
- [Voiceover] Although Dracula
is considered the kickoff
of the Universal monster
series, the studio's founder,
Carl Laemmle Jr really
set the mold earlier
when he produced The Phantom of the Opera.
This 1925 silent film adaption
of the Phantom of the Opera
also gave us our first
jump scare on screen,
but more on that later.
(spooky music)
Where the early monster movies
just presented a villain
built to scare and didn't
focus on the bloody acts
they were committing, as horror
films became more prevalent,
Frankenstein's scarred
face would prove not enough
to get audiences on the
edge of their seats.
It was time to bring on the blood.
Many early Hollywood films
leaned into horror and gore,
and their popularity
inadvertently derailed
that part of the genre for years.
(crowd singing)
Tod Browning's Freaks
in 1932 was so horrific,
even after several edits,
it prompted Hollywood to enact
the Hays Production Code,
which cut down on the
sex, gore and violence
that we horror fans have
come to know and love.
In response to the Hays
Codes, filmmakers had to rely
on innuendo, clever camera work, scoring
and the use of dread and
suspense to horrify film fans.
The artistry behind that became the norm
and no one did it better
than the master himself,
Alfred Hitchcock.
- We all go a little mad sometimes.
Haven't you?
- [Voiceover] Let's take a peek
at his infamous shower scene
from Psycho, a moment from
a movie that is so iconic,
it is the basis of an entire documentary
and has been imitated countless times.
(shower running)
(woman screams)
A moment of violence with
very little blood or gore
that suggests an idea so unnerving,
movies themselves would never be the same.
(woman screaming)
Hitchcock was dubbed
the master of suspense,
and if you just have a
listen to his Bomb Theory,
you'll understand why.
- Four people are sitting around a table
talking about baseball, whatever you like.
Suddenly a bomb goes off.
What did the audience have?
10 seconds of shock.
Now take the same scene
and tell the audience
there was a bomb under that table,
and will go off in five minutes.
Well, the whole emotion of the
audience is totally different
because you've given
them that information.
- [Voiceover] That type of suspense
is what John Krasinski
used in A Quiet Place.
The opening sequence is
essentially a cinematic way
of communicating that there's
a bomb in the floor boards
without saying anything.
(toy trilling)
We see the family scared and silent,
we know there's a reason
why they can't talk
and then the spaceship
becomes the ticking bomb.
Oh, that poor kid.
(creature screeches)
For 30 years, the Hays Code
of straight edge filmmaking
was the law of the land,
and during that time,
filmmakers like Hitchcock,
Stanley Kubrick,
Billy Wilder and others
used creative methods
to incite fear while keeping things PG.
- Open the pod bay doors, Hal.
- [Hal] I'm sorry Dave,
I'm afraid I can't do that.
- [Voiceover] I mean,
look at 1944's Gaslight,
which gave Ingrid Bergman
her first Oscar win
and gave the Internet some new slang.
It's the dread the audience feels
will happen to our heroine that hooks us.
Bergman gives great face as
she despairs and questions
if what she's seeing is real.
- I can see you still
standing there and saying,
"Look, look at this letter",
and staring at nothing.
- What?
- You had nothing in your hand!
- [Voiceover] This is the
reverse of what happens
to Elizabeth Moss in The Invisible Man,
but the dread created is the same.
In the 2020 film, we don't feel dread
over whether she'll figure it out,
it's more the dread that
no one will believe her
and the other horrors inflicted upon her.
- [Cee] James, it was him!
He's here, I swear to you.
- Enough, enough!
Cee, enough.
- [Voiceover] This is the same
reason why we fall in love
with the final girls that nobody believes,
like Laurie Strode, Ellen
Ripley and Sidney Prescott.
Well, at least we do
if they don't have sex,
but more on that later.
Besides using dread and suspense
to ratchet up the scares,
Gaslight also employed one of
the other tried and true ways
to scare the audience, by
making the spouse the villain.
Suddenly, nothing is safe,
not your partner, not even the
things and places around you.
In the hands of a horror master,
something innocuous in normal life
becomes sinister on screen,
like birds or the sound of
wind, spiders or heights,
or even your childhood doll or pet.
(woman gasping)
Several horror masters reveled in the idea
that life is more disturbing
than the most evil movie monster.
Sometimes, that meant that
you should fear birds.
Sometimes, that meant that you should fear
the system we live in,
or how we live in it.
Jordan Peele used the horrors of racism
and the marginalization of black Americans
to create the sunken place.
- So the movie, for me, became
almost about representation
within the genre, within
itself, in a weird way.
- [Voiceover] Ari Aster
used the cult sub-genre
to turn the idea of a fun
summer vacation on its head
and to explore grief
and toxic masculinity,
all while featuring a ton of
gore as, well, just a bonus.
(man falls)
And just earlier this year,
Natalie Erika James framed Alzheimer's
as a gruesome horror plot point
for the equally terrifying Relic.
Camera, scoring, lighting.
- Nice boy.
- [Voiceover] Dread and
the presence of monsters
all work to ignite fear.
(woman screaming)
(horror music)
But it can't be overstated
just how much can be achieved
with the right application of
red corn syrup over pigskin.
(door creaking)
(creature shrieks)
In the 2000s, films like
Hostel, Audition and Saw
reminded audiences what
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre
and slasher films knew all too well.
Blood and gore can terrify
people to their core.
(man running)
(bones breaking)
John Carpenter, Dario Argento,
Roger Corman and George
Romero gave birth to a new era
in horror filmmaking and
solidified the horror tropes
that are now as familiar as A-list stars.
And speaking of familiar,
we couldn't go any further
without (creature shrieks)
mentioning the horror tactic
that gets the most flak,
but remains, to this
day, the most effective:
the jump scare.
(person claps)
The shock of the unexpected crashing noise
or leaping villain is a quick
and cheap way to get screams.
(man gasps)
If a monster or ghost story
doesn't have at least a handful,
it's shocking.
(horror music)
Using camera work and
sound, a director can,
in just a few quick moments,
change the energy around any moment.
(phone ringing)
And that shock is not just reserved
for monsters jumping out of a closet.
Look at the ending of the first Saw film
when Jigsaw gets up after Cary
Elwes has cut off his foot.
The shock in that moment
rivals just about everything
that happened up to that point
as far as how much it affected us.
- Game over.
(person screaming)
- [Voiceover] The same can be said
for Robert Eggers' The Witch.
Though primarily an
atmospheric horror film,
Eggers splices quick cuts
of disturbing pagan imagery
into the nearly silent
film as just another way
to keep the audience ill at ease.
But every aspect of a horror film
becomes a trope after a
certain amount of time.
The virginal heroine, sin equals death.
- There are certain rules
that one must abide by
in order to successfully
survive a horror movie.
- [Voiceover] Yes, basically
all the rules from Scream
took hold in the 1970s and
audiences could not get enough
of the midnight madness
double feature horror films
that filmmakers like Quentin Tarantino
would go on to celebrate
and recreate, or rip off,
depending on who you ask.
But by the time you reach the 1990s
and Jamie Kennedy forever ruined
most of the horror staples
filmmakers had relied on for so long,
the latest and most effective
mode to terrorize us
rose to prominence.
- Get out!
- Yo, yo chill man.
- [Voiceover] And that was the
subversion of expectations,
which is the entire premise
of Cabin in the Woods.
Spoiler alert, the film
lives in the standard
teen horror model until the big reveal,
in which we find out the
events up until that point
are, in fact, a tribute
to the Ancient Ones,
a cruel group of subterranean deities
who are trying to determine
if humanity is worth saving.
- I'm sorry I let you get
attacked by a werewolf
and then ended the world.
- No, you were right.
Humanity.
- [Voiceover] And based on
the current state of events,
I have to agree with the final
scene and say, probably not.
And in the end, the
subversion of expectations
is where we're scaring
people most these days.
As movie audiences became
more sophisticated,
horror directors had to work harder
to get the desired effect,
making the ordinary
seem extraordinarily terrifying or scary.
- Don't open the door.
- [Girl] See?
Everything's okay.
(girl screams)
- [Voiceover] Jordan Peele used the image
of our worst selves
unleashed upon us in Us,
a thousand times scarier
than if it was just another
Freddie-styled villain
slicing up the town.
- Don't burn our house down.
(demonic laughing)
- [Voiceover] And Julia Ducournau
gave vegans and carnivores
something to chew on
with her cannibalistic
gory coming of age tale, Raw.
Subverting our expectations
is the hallmark
of most successful modern
day horror directors.
They call on the ancestors
and borrow just enough
to set the stage, and
then pull away the rules
that they have lived
by to keep us guessing,
and screaming, at the movie
magic they've created.
(demon screaming)
(woman screaming)
And what was this year's
most successful horror film?
The Invisible Man.
Whannell's masterful
in setting expectations
and then making them disappear.
He crafts a symphony of scares
by employing every scare
tactic we've mentioned.
Jump scares are set up but never
happen, leaving us on edge.
Good people die, bad people live.
The movie's an old-school
bloodless suspense thriller
until we swim in pools of the stuff.
And crucially, in the
biggest twist of the tale,
the focus is not on
the man but on a woman.
The terror, almost a
century after Universal
started the genre, is not
what is becoming of him,
but what he's doing to her.
By flipping the script,
Whannell found a fresh way
to frighten us and a path
forward for horror filmmakers,
something horror fans who
thought they knew the genre
inside and out, well, never saw coming.